Our experts and emotion interview today
will be with Doctor Matthew Hurts and
sign. He received his phd from the
University of California Berkeley and he's
currently an associate professor of
psychology at de Paul University where he
directs the touch and emotion laboratory.
So his research is
conducted with students, um,
in three areas including touch and the
communication of emotion as well as the
prediction of emotion
and emotion and infants.
His work has received widespread
media coverage including NPR,
the New York Times,
ABC News,
BBC scientific American
mind and psychology today.
So I now turn to our experts and
emotion interview with Doctor Matthew
Hertenstein.
So what I thought we could start off
I'm talking about is just a little bit
about hearing your story of what first
got you interested in the topic of
emotion.
I mean,
really briefly,
the thing that really got me in
emotion was studying babies. Um,
as you might imagine,
a emotions are the primary means
of communication for events.
They don't obviously have language.
Um,
and so babies are really
where it started for me.
And I still study infants as day,
but I also study in dogs as well.
So these are really what got
me started down the road.
Fantastic.
So I want to ask you now a little bit
about your journey down the road of
emotion and sort of some themes about
some of the really exciting research that
you've done in this domain.
So you're well known for
this really exciting and
influential work on the nature
of touch and emotion. So to begin, for
those who may not have heard of this work,
how can touch function as
a mode of communication in
general and human species?
Great question. Um, it's a question
that we're, we're getting a handle on,
but were there still a lot to learn? There
are a lot more questions than answers.
Um,
but you know,
we see touch in our relationships
with other people. Um,
you know,
with our kids,
with our siblings that we might
have our intimate relationships.
So it bonds us to other people.
Um,
talk is really important in power,
a hierarchy. So you see different,
ah, facets of touch being used
depending on who was powerful,
less powerful. So those differential
relationships you see touching, um,
touched increases liking of other people,
usually as long as it's obviously used
appropriately and in con proper contacts.
Um, so we see it there. Uh,
compliance is a big one.
There's been a lot of research shows
that when we touch other people,
when we ask them for something or
for help or something like that,
touch really increases compliance. So, um,
well known study where a
medical practitioner touches
his or her patient while
telling them that it's important to
take their medicine. And sure enough,
the people who are touched, um, take
their medicine more frequently and w uh,
as instructed versus the people who in a
control condition, you aren't, I still,
compliance is also a big,
big deal,
but what I focus on and it's the how
touch communicates emotion in our
relationships.
So how can touch communicate emotions?
Well, no, there's a variety of ways.
We're just learning about this. I mean,
one of the ways is,
you know,
there are specific receptors
within the skin that are, you know,
no susceptive or another way,
fancy way of saying is just induces
pain pretty easily. Right? So there's,
so some touches just inherently negative,
but then also some touches
inherently positive, right?
So just in terms of the tactile
receptors we have in our skin,
um, they're called, those are
steaming lane will influence how,
what emotions we perceive
through that put a lot of it, um,
is potentially learning. I mean, like I,
I talked to before about
babies and emotion,
I mean touches fundamental to the
relationship between parents and their
offspring.
Um,
so from almost day one were being poached
and stroke and cuddled and all this
sort of stuff, even though by the way
it goes away, um, and most of our,
and adolescents in our adult life,
which we can have a whole nother
discussion about. Okay. Um, but anyway,
so there's a lot of learning and it goes
on because that can mean that language,
so to speak, up of touches the,
to us early in line. And then I'm,
I have no doubt that through some sort
of evolutionary underpinnings to a lot of
this, um, and you know, we can
see a lot of this too, and we,
when we studied chimpanzees or whatnot,
um, so it's a of a combination,
but teasing these things
apart and understanding how
they interact is sort of,
you know,
a future researchers dream.
So one really exciting thing about the
work you've done in this domain is you've
developed this really innovative paradigm
for studying the communication of
touch in a laboratory setting.
And I wonder if you could share
a little bit about this. Um,
I know that the work we've done together
has used your fantastic paradigm and
it's just such an elegant
and a unusual way.
And some people might think of
learning, uh, how we can study,
touch in these contexts.
Yeah, I mean, actually it's
pretty deceptively simple. Um,
we've done it a variety of different
ways. The first time, and we did this,
we had two people I'm sitting across
from each other at a table and that's a
barrier between the two
people. Um, I clock barrier,
so they couldn't see each
other that didn't know.
You didn't know if a male or a female,
Liz sitting across from you to
know their age. They never spoke.
So you've been telling you that.
And then one person was randomly
assigned to put their arm underneath the
curtain and the other person basically
was told to communicate a variety of
different types of emotions
just on the arm. And, um,
the question that we're asking is how
accurate are equal at perceiving those
emotions. Um, and so we
borrowed methodology, um,
from other researchers. You've
studied the face, the boys.
And so this was all on our
own, um, whatsoever. Um,
and essentially we found that sure enough,
uh,
touch communicates you specific emotions.
Um,
I'm the white, the face and the
voice, although some different ones,
which we can talk about. Um, but you know,
before we did the studies,
some researchers tended
to think that I'm not all,
but some researchers tend to think that
touch might communicate positive or
negative emotion,
but nothing specific or the street.
So it's this research line,
uh,
kind of debunks that idea and
shows that we're actually,
it's touches a really sophisticated means
by which we communicate our emotions.
And did you find
specific patterns of touch for
distinct kinds of emotions?
You could say a little bit about,
I wonder if people in the
audience are wondering.
So how does something like anger
look different from love for example?
Right. That's a great question. I mean,
here's the take home message about,
uh,
Bob not,
is there is far more
diversity in how indicate uh,
via touched then there are
specific patterns. So we,
I'm working on,
we,
my collaborators and I are working on
coming up with clinical prototypes for uh,
or refer the tapes of how we might
communicate stinky emotions be attached,
but there's nothing, uh, it's very
difficult to come up with that.
I'm partly because of the
methodology is very, um,
rudimentary right now in
terms of measuring touch.
And so I wouldn't say easy to
measure a facial expression,
but there was a system out there,
right, that we all know that, um,
I'm sure other speakers in
your series discussed. Um,
but there is no such standardized
system and be able to touch.
So we're trying to come up with one of
those so that we can better get a grasp
on what exactly the question
you're asking. Sorry.
I mean your work on touch and emotion
is also revealed some really important
individual differences, right.
In how we perceive, you know,
this touch signal from other people,
sort of what it communicates to us.
And for example,
I wonder if you could say a little bit
perhaps about how men and women may
differ,
you know,
and how they perceive or utilized
touches to communicate emotions.
Well, just for a second, let me back up
and say that in our herd and we, that we,
we'd done both with the arm and then
we've got a whole body touch. Sure. Wow.
And we found that men and women can
communicate a variety of different emotion
like fear or sadness or discuss
low gratitude, sympathy.
All of these are above chance levels that
are common between both men and women.
And notice, by the way, that somebody,
these emotions are the same as what
is communicated, um, accurately.
In the face and the voice. But some
of those emotions are different, um,
in the face and the voice.
And I think that's a good opportunity for,
for future researchers to
have to kind of tackle that.
So he gets to your question
about men and women. Um,
I really wish we were in the
founding differences, frankly, um,
because they sort of support these
stereotypes that some people have. Um,
so I wished we went found gender
differences, but we did and you know,
I have to go where, where nature
and so we found, you know,
in our, in our paradigm, right,
you can have a male, female,
female and touching a male or it can
have two males where you can have a few
females so you can have every
gender a combination possible CSP.
And we found the only gender combination
that was unsuccessful at communicating
anger where all female died. So, um,
if you get two women together and you tell
one to communicate anger to the other,
um, they're not above chance doing
that. If you have a male involved,
um, in, in that grouping,
um, they are able to so,
so that,
so anger seems to be not as easy
for women communicate as men.
And then the other emotion, again,
I wish I didn't find these funny.
I know one of the ones that
we found was a sympathy.
And as you might guess,
um,
meaning we're much
better at this than men.
When you got to have two men together,
they couldn't communicate that above
chance levels. Um, so again, I wish,
I wish I wouldn't have found those,
those gender differences. Um, but I,
you know, we, and we can only take
guesses as to why. I mean is it,
I believe it's near harder, the origins,
our evolutionary heritage in that,
um, you can look to the animal
butcher and see some of that. Um,
but obviously socialization,
you playing a huge role. Um,
and I don't think I would want to
discount that at this point know.
So one other area of individual
differences that I know
you and I have talked a
little bit about is the
role of communicating and
proceeding touch and emotional
disorders. So, for example,
I know you've done some
work in individuals with a
history of mood disorders
like mania.
And I wonder if you could say a little
bit about how their experience of touch
and the way that they,
you know,
perceive touches might be different
from the rest of the population.
That's a great question. Oh, we're just
beginning to get a bead on that. And,
um, one of our art, it's an
a really nice finding, um,
that our group was actually
done is basically looking
at people with people who
are prone to high degrees of positive
emotion. And those people are,
we meet,
I'm somewhat more accurate overall at
perceiving these distinct emotions.
Um, in the paradigm I discussed
with you. And I'm not only that,
but they tend to over attribute,
um,
positive emotions to all the touches
they, they perceive home, um,
uh, people. So this is over
attribution of positive emotion,
sort of under attribution of negative
emotion. So, you know, I don't,
we don't fully understand that completely,
but we know that there is this
individual difference that's,
that's coming out of the data.
Um,
so everything feels good,
right?
Everything feels good and, and
they're, they're more accurate,
which is pretty surprising in some
ways. Um, but maybe it's got another,
so, so yeah, there's, so there's
that individual, their friends,
the gender is really interesting.
One and a team in London actually
published a paper last year,
maybe two years ago,
um,
showing that romantic relationship
status influences perception of touch.
So they found that,
um,
strangers could not communicate
embarrassment to each other via touch,
but romantic couples could.
So there's a nutso relationship status
is also seem to play a role. So I think,
I think that's the individual difference
question is right. Or investigation.
So I wanted to ask you about one other
theme in your work and this has all been
really interesting hearing
you speak about it. Um,
one other area in your work has really
looked at the way that touch can be used
to actually regulate or shaped the
emotions that people experience.
And I wonder if you could say a little
bit about what do you see as the most
important discoveries here about how
touch can actually serve a regulatory
function?
Well, I mean, this is, that's a great
question. I would say it honestly,
it's too early to really get
a good sense of that. Um,
I've studied that in those infants.
Um,
and I think some of the bus working
you've been with the infants,
honestly like using a touch,
caregivers touch with infants to
help them understand, you know,
what is good and what is bad in the
world and how they should understand the
world. Um, so if you introduce an object
that the baby doesn't quite understand,
um, in front of him or her and around
the age of one year old or whatnot, um,
and you touched them positively,
there'll be much more likely to go
approach that, that toy, that object.
And if you touched them, sort of
an, a negative, abrupt manner,
the much more loaning to kind of
retract and not willing to touch that.
And so you're literally influencing their
perception of the objects around them,
the world around them, and perhaps
their emotional state during that. Um,
you know, in terms of adults, um,
there's been some work on that
question, but honestly, not a lot. Um,
one of the kind of promising areas is
honestly is looking at sort of this a
touch therapy,
which I'm not as involved in in my lab.
I'm a woman named Tiffany field,
done in Florida,
has a lot of this work and
she's finding they're really,
really powerful effects on mood and
mental state and astro stock with,
you know, this massage therapy or
therapy. So it's really great for
really fascinating.
So I mean,
I know today we've talked about the role
that touch touched in communicating,
you know,
emotions and the work that you've showing.
They can actually communicate really
distinct types of emotions and can be used
to sort of regulate emotions as well.
So I wonder as you sort of, you know,
moved in this field and really made
some landmark discoveries here,
where do you see the future
of the field moving forward?
Great question. I mean, I, I think, um,
uh, a number of ways I can think about it.
Number one, looking at physiological
underpinnings of all of us. So yeah,
I think that's a natural question. Wide
Open for investigation. Um, and I mean,
you know, central nervous system,
autonomic nervous system. Um,
so I think that's wide open and
we've got some work going on, um,
on that question.
But I mean it really is wide open and
obviously that work has been done for
years and the face looking at
facial expression of emotion, um,
and some of it on the voice,
um, but very little touches.
I think that's one area.
It's wide open.
Another one is just looking at how
the context of real world situations
influenced how pouch is communicated.
So a lot of it, uh, my work,
especially at the none allow,
um,
but I think next step is
to take it out of the lab,
look at this and the real world
has some more ecologically valid,
uh, um, procedures to use, um,
to look at how it touches you
used to communicate in watching.
So I think that's wide open
individual differences. I still,
I mean even though we discovered some
new bit of differences in terms of, um,
how well people patch out perceptions of
that touching when I think that it's a
lot to be discovered in that area.
And then finally looking at
the person as a whole. Right?
So we can talk about touches and modality,
if he can be Katie,
if we can talk about the
faces and modality can be
Kate or the voice or gesture
or whatnot. But how do all of these
come together in the real world,
um,
to communicate emotion,
which ones are really driving the
communication of emotion and how do they
interact with each other?
Um,
we're just beginning to get a
sense of of that and I think,
you know, in the next decade or so, um,
we should be making some
big strides in that area.
So when you have students come to
you asking you for advice, you know,
who are thinking about embarking
in this field of emotion,
what kind of advice might you give them?
Big Question. I mean, just in general,
in the end, beyond my specific area.
Um, I think honestly
asking important questions,
I'm just really working hard
to think about, you know,
what you want to put your time
into because our time is precious.
Resources are precious and you
can ask questions and answer them.
But the question is, is, are,
is what you're studying Wharton,
is it really going to make, um, uh,
impact on the field? So I would
answer important questions, um,
because it's just seen so many people
ask questions that really don't out too
much or maybe a bit, but I mean,
if you're gonna spend your time,
might as well spend your time on a big
question or a set of big questions.
So I would, I would definitely
give that advice. Um, it's,
it's the bonus, I'd
say. Uh, not imperative,
but a bonus if you can study things
that not too many other people studying,
um, having room to make
some of these discoveries,
um, I think is, is wonderful.
So you've done that and other
people we know have done that.
And so I think studying things that not
a lot of people that are involved in,
maybe you don't want to
be the only one of course,
but why I try to study some of the things
that you can make a discovery and help
further the field.
Um,
another one is integrating multiple
methods I think is always a great thing.
In almost any field in psychology.
So using physiological measures of self
report, measure behavior, all measures,
all of these. And trying to bring them
together to answer your question, um,
in different research designs I think
is really important. And then finally,
you know, when, when you are in
graduate school or what you are doing,
your boss doc find to find people that
study emotion using these different
tools, you know, having great team, um,
so that you can really learn from the
box I think is really important to you.
So asking you to important questions,
studying something that ideally
nobody knows too much about. Um,
integrating multiple methods and then
finally finding those people that can help
you learn those tools,
I think are,
are some of the keys to see who pretty
providing some good solid research in the
field and moving along.
Well,
thank you so much.
That's excellent advice cause I just
want to thank you again for joining us
today.
Matt,
this concludes our experts in emotion
interview with Doctor Matthew Hertenstein
from de Paul University.